[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
I'm Peter-Mark Verwoerd.
I'm a Solutions Architect
here at Google Cloud,
and I specialize in
helping customers migrate.
So I go and see a
lot of customers
as they made the decision
to come to Google Cloud
or in the process about thinking
about moving to Google Cloud.
I help educate them
about various aspects
of the cloud and kind of
what advantages it can offer.
And also, in particular,
how to take what they have
and what they are using
and migrate that over.
In the course of what I do, a
question that comes up a lot
is, OK, great.
How much does this cost?
What is this going to cost me?
What's the bottom line?
And I think that we tend to
focus these conversations
particularly on data processing
and data processing pipelines.
Because I think those
are more conceptually
difficult to price out.
I think to a certain extent,
if you understand the way
that, say, a web front
end or a database
works and the capacity
that it needs to meet,
that it's relatively
straightforward
to be able to price
that out in the cloud,
even if you're not entirely
familiar with that environment.
But data processing
pipelines tend
to bring in so many
different kinds of products
and so many different
moving pieces
that it tends to be a lot more
difficult. It's not impossible,
but it tends to be a
lot more difficult.
So a lot of our conversations
end up focusing on that.
And so what I'd
like to do right now
is just walk through what
those conversations are
like that I go through
with customers that I meet.
And kind of help you
out and giving you
some sort of context
and guidelines
towards doing this on your own.
But first, I just
want to start out
with a relatively
simple metaphor.
What am I pointing to?
I am pointing to nothing.
There.
So think for a
second if you could
try to purchase
energy for your home
for like the next three
years all in once.
Do you think it'd be possible to
kind of get that number exactly
right?
Do you think you could do it
efficiently so that you're not
overpaying?
Do you think you could do it in
such a way that would actually
make sense?
I mean, like what would happen
if you bought not enough energy
or you bought way too
much and your lights
are on all the time?
So this is why I
think companies that
are approaching the cloud are
sometimes confused by the way
things are priced.
The way products are
priced is that it's
fundamentally different
from the way people
are used to pricing out
infrastructure and pricing
out resources.
It can be very confusing.
This, by the way, is the
head of the SA program.
This is a guy named Miles Ward.
We frequently make
GIFs of each other
and use them in presentations
because I think it's hilarious.
So the reason why
it's different,
and the reason why I
use the energy analogy,
is because cloud pricing
is utility pricing.
It's based on what you use.
It's not something that
is pre-provisioned.
And I think that's a mind
shift from somebody who's
coming in with a expectation
of the way things are purchased
inside a data center.
And so if you look at
the way cloud pricing is,
if you're familiar with
how data center works,
I think it can be
somewhat confusing.
So if you approach
this from somebody
who's got a good
understanding, like
I know how to price out in
the next three to five years,
whatever that is, within a
reasonable amount of accuracy
given a certain
amount of growth.
But I come and look at
what the cloud offers.
That is different from
what I'm looking at.
So if you look at
things like services
that are charged
by, say, the amount
of storage per month, things
that have streaming and batch
processing, and then
products with storage
and streaming and
querying pricing,
this is all very different.
It's all bundled together
in very, very different ways
if you're used to being
able to purchase something
as a physical device.
And so if you come to
that and you think,
does this make sense?
If somebody asks
you, like here's
how Cloud Storage, here's
how BigQuery is priced.
Does this makes sense?
Sometimes, maybe, actually
I'm not really sure.
And so these are the
kind of conversations
we want to have with our
customers and say like,
this is how you can make
sense of what this is
and how you can make sense
of what we're doing and how
that maps to what
you're used to.
And so we take the
conversation through to,
this is where a lot of
data center pricing is
and how you should see that
relate to what the cloud does.
So there are generally two ways
that you can purchase capacity
in a data center.
The first way is regular
capacity planning.
You have some sort of regular
timeframe where you buy things.
You have a certain
amount of capacity
that you buy during
that timeframe.
Whether it's by some sort of
metric, some sort of decision
process.
Whatever it is, it's a regular
path that people follow.
The other way is
when you fall out
of that pattern where
there is some sort
of out-of-band purchase
for whatever reason
and you're making
something off-schedule.
But purchasing capacity
for a data center
isn't just buying new servers.
It's buying storage media,
buying racks, power,
networking, routers, switches,
whatever the case may be.
Yeah, space even.
Hiring new people.
These are all things that--
oh, thank you.
These are all things that are
affected by the purchasing
that you make.
Does that work?
It seems like not.
In any case.
What's wrong with that?
I mean, there are
lots of customers
and there are a lot
of companies out there
that are highly successful.
They're running in data centers.
That's not connected.
OK.
And they're doing just fine.
People are running highly
successful businesses in just--
oh.
OK.
I'm sorry about that.
It works.
Oh, yeah.
It does.
So there are lots of companies
that are kind of highly
successful at doing this.
And so why kind of change
the way things are priced?
And I think at
Google Cloud, we feel
like this method of
purchasing is not ideal.
Let's kind of talk about why.
So in the first scenario
why this might not be ideal,
let's say you're on
a development team.
You've created a new product.
You've created a new
feature, whatever that is.
You need extra capacity.
You reach out to
operations and say,
we need x kind of capacity.
And the answer is hopefully yes.
And hopefully being
able to deploy something
isn't the best strategy.
The worst answer of
course, is rather
than getting a hopefully yes,
you can get definitely not.
We're out of capacity
until the next cycle.
That's also bad.
Because then whatever
you plan on releasing
to your customers,
whatever needs to come out
there, whatever work
your team has done
is not going out there.
And so that's not
a great experience.
On the other hand, if you're
doing capacity planning,
the two scenarios you
see your capacity at
is either you are
under-provisioned when
you've purchased something
new and people have not fully
moved in yet or you
are overcapacity
or you're oversubscribed.
People are not able to
use as much capacity
as they would like to because
you don't have enough.
And neither of those
scenarios are ideal.
In the out-of-band purchase,
there are similar issues.
Except what you're
coming across now
is because this is unusual,
because this is not planned,
each one of these is kind
of this own unique snowflake
of an issue.
And so a development team
has created something new.
Hey, management says
this has to go out now.
We need the capacity.
It's got to support
a million users.
And operations says, OK.
What does a million users mean
in terms of how many cores
do we have to buy?
How much storage do we need?
And it depends dramatically
on the use case.
And so you have this point
where either operations
needs to translate what the
development team has told them.
And hopefully, come up
with accurate numbers
as to what that might mean
for the hardware to purchase.
Or, the development
team says, we're
going to guess that what
we need is this much cores
and this much RAM.
And we think we're right.
And that translation
is not easy, even
for people with a
lot of experience.
It can go wrong.
And it's frequently
difficult to do.
Or worse yet, maybe
you've created a feature
and nobody has any idea
how much capacity you need.
This is something totally new.
We're testing something out.
We could be totally wrong.
We have no idea what to ask for.
Or, again, you have somebody
who says, you know what?
This is going to be
the hot, new thing.
We're going to do great.
We're going to need millions
and millions of users.
And it comes out and actually,
not that many people.
So you've got all
this wasted capacity.
The other end of the spectrum,
it's like, you know what?
It's a tiny, little feature.
No one will ever see it.
And suddenly, it becomes
the next new thing.
So all these sorts of things
lead to problems with the way
that purchasing happens.
And so we think
at Google Cloud we
can try to help change
the way people think
about purchasing what
they need, purchasing
infrastructure and supporting
the applications that they
want to deploy.
So
So we designed
Google Cloud pricing
to be as flexible for
customers as possible.
We're not trying to make you
commit to long-term pricing,
to choose machine
types, to choose zones,
to choose regions.
We want to be flexible
for customers.
So we've done a number of
things that kind of enable this.
One of them is
sustained use discounts,
which give you a discount
at the end of the month,
depending on how long you've
run your virtual machines
without any
interaction from you.
We're just saying, OK.
You used it for this long.
This is what the discount is.
It just happens.
Things like preemptable
virtual machines,
which are great for
batch, and interruptible
workloads where you
just need more capacity
but have the ability
to be able to stand
to lose a worker or two.
Those are great because you can
run these in data processing
pipelines.
Require a lot of
capacity, but you
can stand to lose some things.
And it just keeps
going, picking up
new preemptable virtual
machines at something
like 80% of the cost of a
regular virtual machine.
And finally, permanent billing.
So actually, billing you by the
minute for the virtual machines
you're running so that you're
really only just paying
for the things you use,
which is kind of the way
we think cloud pricing
should work inherently.
Custom machine types is
something interesting
that we launched,
I think last year.
Maybe the year before.
Because we saw a lot of
customers asking, look.
We've got these workloads
that say I need 20, 24 cores
to run x workload.
And you've got 16 core machines.
You've got 32.
So I'm constantly
over-provisioning,
spending a lot more money
than I actually need to.
And we kind of don't
want you to do that.
Everything at Google runs
on top of a container.
So our virtual machines actually
also run on top of containers.
It actually gives us a lot of
flexibility in how we design
and how we build out
our virtual machines.
So we said, well, we have a
standard set of instance types.
We feel like they meet a
lot of general use cases.
If they don't meet your use
case, then design it yourself.
You can put together
what kind of--
however much CPU, however
much RAM you need.
And then you can actually
rightsize your workloads.
And what we've seen is it's
had a huge impact where
a lot of customers say, OK,
this actually fits my workload.
I am not over-provisioned.
I'm not paying for
more than I need.
And like the slide says,
up to like 19% savings
versus before when you were
constantly over-provisioning
if you weren't quite where we
created these standard instance
types.
We constantly support as much
of the open source community
as we possibly can.
We are big fans of the
open source community.
We contribute to it a lot.
Things like TensorFlow,
like Apache Beam,
like our white papers for
MapReduce and Bigtable
and all these sorts of things.
And the reason we do that
is because we know customers
are using a lot of
these third-party tools,
a lot of open source tools.
Everyone, everywhere is using
something somewhere like that.
And we want to be able
to support everyone.
And what we don't want
to do is have a platform
where you're using our platform
and staying on our platform
because you cant leave because
you've got proprietary APIs,
because you've got proprietary
inoperable or interchangeable
services with something
else that you want to use.
And so if you bring in your
data to Google Cloud Storage,
if you bring into Dataproc,
if you bring into BigQuery,
and then one day you
want to move it out.
You know what?
Actually, BigQuery's
not doing it for me.
I want to use this other tool.
Bigtable isn't quite
right for this use case.
I'm going to drop
it into Cassandra.
We want to be able to
support that and have
the interoperability.
We don't want to
keep you locked in.
We want you to use
Google Cloud because you
want to use Google Cloud.
Because you find it
the most advantageous.
So it should be
kind of obvious now
that the way we consider
pricing and the way
we price things is based
entirely on how you use it
and for how long you use
it and how much you're
consuming rather than asking you
to ever kind of pre-provision
and pre-approve or
try to figure out
in advance how much capacity
you're going to be using.
So within that lens,
I think the difference
between buying physical hardware
and managing, say, a data
center, managing racks,
and all those sorts
of things, versus how you manage
capacity planning in the cloud
starts to make a lot more sense.
And so with that in
mind, what I'd like to do
is just walk through a few
of the-- well, not a few.
Most of the data
processing-related services
that we have.
And kind of talk about
the way they're priced.
And talk about ways that
we see customers kind
of looking for
particular cost drivers
in how they're being used.
And again, the reason why I
like to focus on data processing
as opposed to, say, compute
like Container Engine or Compute
Engine, or so on, is I think
because so many of these things
tie-in together.
And that data
processing environments
tend to be much more
complex, that it's
important to understand how
these are individually priced,
and then how they're
priced together.
So the first one I'm going
to talk about is Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is scalable
messaging, push/pull globally.
This is another one
of these services
that Google uses
extensively internally.
We use Pub/Sub
messaging constantly.
And so this is the
same service that's
exposed to Cloud customers.
Pub/Sub recently
changed its pricing
to be only based on
storage, which actually
makes this pretty easy.
There are no multiple
dimensions to watch.
It's nothing for me
to really explain.
It's all storage.
So how much storage are you
actually consuming on Pub/Sub?
And so it's not
pre-provisioning topics.
It's not pre-provisioning
messages.
kind of anything.
It's how much storage are
you putting out on Pub/Sub?
And that's the real cost driver.
Cloud storage, scalable
object storage.
Similar to Pub/Sub,
it's based on how much
storage are you using.
How much data are
you putting in there?
And that's how much we charge.
We're not going to, again, ask
you to pre-provision anything.
It's just, what is in there?
What goes out there?
The thing to watch
for Cloud Storage
is there are multiple
storage classes.
And this is
interesting and useful
because each of
these storage classes
have different use cases
and useful use cases,
but it depends on what
you're using them for.
Multi-regional,
like the slide says,
it's really good for lowering
the latency to end users,
to getting your data to end
users as quickly as possible
from your storage buckets.
It's not about caching.
But actually, pushing out
unique data to your end users
as quickly as possible.
Those are available
across continents.
So you can have multi-regional
US, multi-regional Europe,
multi-regional Asia.
And it will spread the
data around those areas.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Could you
just remember it for the end,
please?
Could you remember the
question for the end, please?
We will have a Q&A.
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Thank you.
So near line and cold
line are varying levels
of archival storage, depending
on how frequently are they
accessed.
And then subsequently, they're
cheaper depending on that.
Regional storage is kind
of what it sounds like.
It stays within the region.
And I think for most data
processing pipelines,
regional storage is what
most customers end up
using because a lot
of data processing
involves data locality.
So you want your
data to be nearby
so it can interact with various
services as you use them.
So regional storage tends
to be what customers end up
using for data processing.
This one, I will have to read.
So for some
perspective, a terabyte
in regional storage in the
US costs $20.48 for 1 month.
And a petabyte for 1
month is $20,971.52.
So just some range
of numbers there.
So Cloud Bigtable is a scalable
high-speed NoSQL Database.
It's priced essentially
across two dimensions,
across how many nodes
you've provisioned
and how much storage
you're actually using.
So the important things to
note here, there are three.
One, you have to provision
at least three nodes.
And two, the storage can be
either SSD or spinning disk,
hard drive disks.
And three, like the
balance between-- this
is one of the few cases where
you do actually pre-provision.
Is the balance between
pre provisioning
nodes for query capacity
or operational capacity
versus storage, which is
just build as you consume it.
So when we get questions about,
how do you price out Bigtable?
What's the big cost driver?
Unfortunately, this is
kind of where guidance
gets a little more difficult.
Because as a database, it's got
a huge variety of use cases.
So it's going to
depend significantly
on how you use it.
But some loose guidelines.
If you find that
you're using Bigtable
to drive a lot of
operations, you're
doing a lot of reads
and writes, then
the number of nodes
that you have tends
to be the big cost driver.
If, on the other hand, you
are storing a lot of data and
you're not doing a
lot of operations.
Then, obviously, storage is
going to be more significant.
But that might be a scenario
where you start considering,
is Bigtable the right
choice for this use case?
And this is a little
tangential from this talk,
but it comes up
so often, is there
are a lot of storage products.
There are a lot of
database products
available on Google Cloud.
Which one's the right
one for what I'm doing?
Because it seems
like a few of them
could actually do this use case.
Could cover this use case.
And the answer is
often, well, yeah.
Actually, you're right.
A few of them could
cover that use case.
And so sometimes,
the data actually
tells you fairly obviously
what you should be doing.
You know what?
I need something that's
strongly consistent.
I need relatable tables.
And I only need it to
be in this one zone.
OK, that's a SQL database.
I don't really have
relatable data.
I've got something that's super,
super high-speed, lots of reads
and writes.
I'm not going to be [INAUDIBLE].
OK, that's probably Bigtable.
But there's a lot of
use cases that kind of
fall in the gray areas, in
between different product
types.
And so figuring out
which one to use
and which one's the
best for each scenario
can actually can be-- it can
be difficult to figure out
without knowing more about
the specific use case.
And that usually generally comes
down to a bit of experience,
a bit of best practices, and
a bit of experimentation.
So now, this discussion
about whether you
should be using
Bigtable or data store
if you're storing a lot of data
but not doing a lot of traffic.
It's going to depend a lot
on what a lot of traffic
actually means.
I'm sorry.
So anyway.
Final part about Bigtable
is the cost driver
is in terms of storage.
Are you using SSDs or are
you using hard drives?
If you've ever purchased
storage before for pretty much
anything, it's the same rule.
SSDs perform more quickly,
but are more expensive.
So Dataproc is a managed
Hadoop and SPARC service.
So it is the same Hadoop that
you could download and run
your own.
It's just managed by us.
We put it on top of
virtual machines.
Dataproc, the pricing
is very straightforward.
It is just a additional charge
on top of the virtual machines
that are running underneath.
So the regular Compute
Engine charges remain,
and then we put an
additional charge
on for how much
Dataproc you're using.
So again, finding out
or trying to explain
what is a typical use case on
Dataproc is kind of difficult.
There's a lot of versatility
to what you can do with Hadoop.
A lot of different use cases.
And so having
specific guidelines
tends to be very difficult
unless you know more
about the use case.
Broadly, really, really
broadly speaking,
if they are temporary clusters.
If they are transient
clusters, the number of cores
tends to be the
biggest cost driver.
If it's a permanent
cluster, it tends
to actually skew the other
way and the amount of storage
that you have provisioned
for the cluster.
But again, it's highly
dependent on use case.
Cloud Dataflow is our
next-generation stream
and batch processing tool.
Again, this is based
on a lot of work
that we've done internally.
Based on MillWheel
and FlumeJava.
And this tends to be more of
the kind of data processing work
that Google uses internally.
Dataflow prices in two
kind of different cases.
It prices whether you're
running a batch job
or whether you're
running a streaming job.
And within that, then
it just prices on,
what are the resources
you're consuming?
What are you consuming in terms
of cores, in terms of RAM,
in terms of storage?
So when using
Dataflow, again, this
is going to sound a bit
repetitive because it's
the same sort of story
as it is for Dataproc.
It depends so much on
the kind of use case.
And with ETL tools, with data
processing tools, especially
things that sit so core to
what so many companies do,
the kinds of prices that it can
drive vary very, very wildly.
So it's kind of hard to
come up with very, very
specific guidance.
But loosely speaking,
what you want
to look at when you're adding
Dataflow to a particular data
processing pipeline is whether
this is going to be batch
or it's going to be streaming.
And also, important to
note and kind of nice,
Dataflow also charges
by the minute.
So by the minute
for the resources
that you're actually consuming.
Big Query.
So Big Query is Google's
no ops, massively scalable
data warehouse.
That's actually also one of
our older Cloud products.
And also, used extensively
internally as Dremel.
Other than that, it's actually
almost exactly the same thing.
So BigQuery essentially
charges you on two dimensions.
On the amount of
storage you're actually
using and the amount
of queries that you're
running, which is actually
really straightforward.
So storage, it's
what you put in.
It's what you're consuming.
No pre-provisioning.
Except that if data
remains untouched
for an extended period of
time, BigQuery actually
ages it into cheaper storage
automatically for you
Queries are, again,
relatively straightforward.
It's charged on the number of
queries that you're-- or that
the amount of data that you're
run per query is the amount
you're charged.
And so that's relatively
straightforward to understand.
Although, a lot of customers
approaching BigQuery kind of
don't have a good sense
of, well, how much data do
my queries consume?
And so there's a bit
of experimentation
that has to happen there.
There is one other thing with
BigQuery in that we have also
added flat-rate pricing, which
basically means that you can
query as much as
you want per month
and you're just
paying one flat rate.
So if you've got a scenario
where you're using a lot,
a lot of queries.
Say you've created a data set or
tables for a group of analysts.
Then, you can say,
you know what, guys?
We're not even going to worry
about how many queries you're
going to make.
Go nuts.
We've done flat-rate pricing.
Generally speaking, the
cost drivers kind of
depend on what you're
using BigQuery for.
We see broadly about two models.
One where BigQuery is constantly
having lots and lots of data
added to it, more
and more over time.
And queries kind of
happen in line with that.
But generally, the data tends
to drive the price there more.
The opposite side
is where you've
got data that's relatively
fixed in terms of how long
it's there, but lots
and lots of queries.
And so more of an
analytical use case.
Then, the queries tend to
drive the costs there more.
So that's just an overview
over the different products
that we have available in
terms of data processing.
There's, obviously, a lot
more that we could go into.
There are a lot of databases
that I didn't really
touch on, like Cloud
SQL, Spanner, data store.
But I feel like the
ones that we covered
are really the ones that are
very essential and almost
always used in some capacity
in data processing pipelines.
So while that's interesting,
I feel like it's not really
entirely useful to talk about
products in the abstract
unless you can talk about
how they all work together.
And I feel like putting
products together
in how they work is really
one of the more useful things
to do.
And so one of the missions of
the solution architecture team
is to help customers
figure out how
to glue all the different
products together.
And actually, that's--
generally speaking,
for most of the
people on my team,
that's actually what we
really super-enjoy doing.
It's Not talking
about x, y, z product,
but talking about how all these
three products work together
to make something awesome.
And so what I'd like
to do now is actually
walk through a few--
three example
architectures focused
on kind of data processing.
I got these architectures
from my colleagues.
And we have a kiosk,
actually, out on the floor.
On all three floors.
So there's one here.
There's one on the second floor.
And there are two downstairs
in the main expo hall.
We call them treehouse.
So basically, you can
go in there and search
or click around
for a whole variety
of use cases,
different industries,
different verticals.
Start clicking into
specific use cases
and a lot of
architectures pop up,
details, pricing, why you
use this, why you use that.
And there's always
a member of our team
sitting there or standing there
to explain how they're used.
So I'm going to
steal three of those
and walk you through them.
This picture, by the way,
was about nine months ago,
we had a bit of a
team meeting face
to face, which we rarely get
to do because we're pretty
well spread around the globe.
And that was in Seattle.
And that's me in the corner
not paying attention.
So the first one we're
going to go through
is a very common
one that we see.
It's called log processing.
It's relatively straightforward.
But even with that
being said, we're
still using several
different data
processing services to
collect and analyze the data.
So how do you price
something like this?
Approaching this, how
do you price that out?
Because you're using so
many different services.
But actually, when
you can look at this
is that it only comes down to
about two different things.
First, how quickly are the logs
coming into this architecture
is going to be a
big cost driver.
And then secondly, how
much storage are you using?
So the inbound data,
the streaming data,
is going to be
really affected by
or is going to really affect--
log collection is going to
affect the streaming or batch
processing in Dataflow and
the ingest into BigQuery.
The storage, on
the other hand, is
going to be the big cost driver
for Cloud Storage, obviously.
But the nature of
this environment
means that it's
actually relatively
transient on cloud storage.
It's not staying
there long term.
The storage is really
coming out of BigQuery.
And so even though we're using
several different services
here, you can actually
break this down
into just kind of
two broad buckets.
How quick is the rate of ingest?
And that's going to affect
the cost of Pub/Sub,
the cost of Dataflow.
And how much
storage am I putting
into BigQuery in the end?
And the second one is
time series analysis.
This one is a
little more complex.
But actually, looking
at it the same way
that we looked at
the previous one,
I think we can start
breaking it down.
So the first important
point is that it's--
similarly to the first
one, the rate of ingest
is going to be a
very big cost driver
into looking at what its
effects on Pub/Sub and Dataflow.
Now, the second thing is
what's going on down here.
The downstream end
of this architecture
is going to be a
significant cost driver.
It looks-- well, I mean,
it is very complicated.
There are a lot of
different things going on.
Basically, because
you can interact
with a lot of our different
tools in different ways
to get different
results out of them.
Whether you're using machine
learning to run predictions.
Whether you're using data lab
to do more interactive queries
for, say, data scientists.
If you're using a
database to do queries.
Whatever the case may be,
there's a lot of versatility
and a lot of interplay
between there.
But despite all that.
So we're using six separate
services right there
at the far end there.
Really, it actually
comes down to two things
that you need to
concern yourself with.
Because all you're
doing right now
is you're analyzing and storing.
So analysis is driven primarily
by how much compute you're
consuming.
And storage is storage.
So are you doing a
lot more analytics
relative to how
much you're storing?
In which case, the compute
cost of that far end
is going to be a
bigger cost driver.
On the other hand, is this
mostly a storage system?
And you're storing a lot of
data and less frequently doing
queries over it?
In which case, the storage is
going to be the cost driver.
And the other thing, actually
this is very important.
Not so much for
the previous one--
for this.
But in this case and
in the next case,
not everyone is going
to use every single part
of these architectures
that we design.
We have customers who have
implemented all of them,
but not necessarily every
part of every architecture
that you see.
So in this case, let's say
you have no use for machine
learning out of this.
Or, you don't really want
to use data lab, or whatever
the case may be, that
significantly decreases
the level of complexity
in terms of figuring out
what this is going to cost.
And then finally,
complex event processing.
So I think this architecture
is very appropriately named.
There's a lot going on here.
But I think we can use what
we talk about in the first two
to kind of help figure
out what's going on here
and give yourself clues to be
able to plan out how to price
this out appropriately.
So first off, we have the
amount of data that's inbound.
So the rate of ingest is always
going to be a big cost driver.
That's going to affect
how you use Pub/Sub.
It's going to affect how you
do streaming jobs on Dataflow.
And then, on the back end,
how much are you querying?
How much are you storing?
How much are you using this for?
How long are you
keeping this storage?
Is this long term,
the final destination?
Is this something
that needs to be held
onto for regulatory reasons?
Is this something you need
to keep for whatever reason?
Maybe you need to
keep it forever.
In which case, storage is going
to incrementally just take over
the cost of everything else.
Or, is this some
sort of system where
we're processing something.
We're getting some sort
of analytics out of it.
We're getting some
sort of result.
And then it's being
aged off later
on to, say, archival storage
classes and cloud storage.
And so those kinds
of things are going
to be key to be able to
understand what is going
to be the big cost driver here.
And again, like
the previous one,
while we have
customers that have
deployed this particular
architecture, we have not--
actually, we probably do have
somebody who's done all of it.
But for the most part, people
don't necessarily do all of it.
This is one in particular
that's very much
a smorgasbord of architecture.
You're going to pick the
parts that make sense for you.
Maybe you don't need
batch processing
coming out of your data center.
Or, maybe you don't have
a rules execution engine.
Maybe you don't want
to use Dataflow.
Maybe you have nothing to
push down to downstream users.
Whatever the case may
be, you don't necessarily
have to implement
the whole thing.
And again, that makes the
job of appropriately pricing
this out significantly
less complicated.
So however you do
that, I think it's
important to have
an understanding
of the products that are
being used and how they price.
But I think it's a lot more
important to see them work
together before you can really
come up with an accurate
representation of what you're
actually going to be spending.
So you can say,
well, I think I'm
pushing about a million messages
through Pub/Sub a month.
What's that going to cost
me overall when I move?
Well, that's an
interesting question.
But how are those
messages being used?
What are you doing with them?
How long are you retaining them?
What's the policy?
And where are they coming from?
Where are they going to?
It's much more difficult to
think about singular products
and how much they're going
to cost without finding out
how much they're going to do.
And so this is a
kind of exercise
that we go through on the
solution architect team.
And actually, other
teams do this a lot, too.
Say, all right.
Tell us about
everything you're using,
and then we can start working
together and figuring out
how much that's going to cost.
This is all kind of part
of the process we go
through a lot with customers.
And what we do also--
and this can be very
helpful-- is actually work
with our pricing calculator.
And say, OK.
Well, this is kind of
our ballpark number.
This is what we
think it will cost
based on what you've told us,
based on what your usage is.
Here, let's come up
with a few numbers.
And so what I'd like
to do is actually
walk through that right now.
Oh.
Before I do that.
Actually, what I'm
going to do is try
to price out this architecture.
But first, I'm going to kind
of say what exactly we're
going to try to price out.
So what I'm going to avoid is
the non-data focus [AUDIO OUT]
I just lost-- oh, no.
I'm back.
Avoid the data, the
non-data processing aspect.
So the inputs, especially
from on-premise and the cloud
application up there,
and then the outputs.
So onto downstream
systems, onto App Engine.
And data lab I am going to
skip, simply because its use
cases can vary so wildly.
It's actually quite
difficult to price out
without knowing a
lot more specifics.
But the rest of this,
we're going to try.
Oh, and one other thing.
I'm just going to
arbitrarily make
the rule, execution
engine Dataproc.
Because there's a lot
of data flow going on,
so I want some variety.
But now let's hop
into the calculator.
There.
There we go.
Could you switch?
What's going on here?
There it is.
OK.
This is actually
just the Home page.
So I'm going to walk
you through this.
If you go over to
Pricing, there's
a lot of things going
on here on this page.
A lot of really
interesting information.
But what we want
are the calculators.
And we're going to go down
to the pricing calculator.
There are a few other things
here that are interesting.
And I suggest you take some
time to take a look at them.
But we don't need to
look at that right now.
So first one we're
going to look at,
we're going to look
at Cloud Storage.
And let's say we're processing--
that looks weird.
Let's say we're processing
10 terabytes a month.
And we're just going to use
that uniformly across all
these different devices.
So that's 10 terabytes
of Cloud Storage.
That's $200 a month.
That's pretty good.
BigQuery.
Let's stick with
our 10 terabytes.
10.
Streaming inserts.
Another 10.
And why not?
Renew 10 terabytes of queries.
That's not bad.
That's a little
under $1,000 a month.
And this is where you can also
see the flat-rate pricing.
What is going on here?
OK.
No.
Come on.
There we go.
OK.
So I'm on Dataproc.
So master nodes tend to not
consume a lot of resources,
depending on your use
case pretty strongly.
In this case, I'm going
to go for something that's
mostly middle of the road.
I'm going to use an 8 standard.
But we are going to use
preemptable VMs as our worker
nodes.
The calculator
will automatically
add 2 regular virtual
machines, which
you have to have when
you use preemptables.
But for the most part, we're
going to use the preemptables.
And we're going to
add, I don't know, 20?
20 sounds like a good number.
Hours this cluster is
going to run per month.
Let's say the batch
jobs run twice a day.
So it's going to run
60 times a month.
Let's say it runs for
about 3 hours each time.
So that's 6 hours a day.
I think that's 180
hours per month.
Yeah.
Wait.
Don't do that.
So let's add that
to the estimate.
And that is-- how much is that?
$172 a month.
That's not bad.
All right.
Let's go back because
I scrolled too fast.
And now-- all right.
I'm going to save
Dataflow for last.
And we have to add some
Bigtable and Pub/Sub.
So Bigtable, we're just
going to do the minimum.
We're going to add three nodes.
Each node provides 10,000
operations per second,
essentially.
So a minimum size storage
node is 30,000 per second.
So I think that
should be sufficient
for this particular use case.
And we're going to add
another 10 terabytes of SSD.
And that is going to cost us
a little over $3,000 a month.
And then, Pub/Sub.
Again, super-easy.
Only the amount of storage
that we're going to be using.
And that is going to
cost us $600 a month.
All right.
Now, let's get back to Dataflow.
Nope.
Wrong direction.
Yeah.
Here we go.
So we have two types of jobs in
that particular architecture.
We've got batch and stream.
So let's do this one.
So we said we're going
to do this twice a day.
So let's just say
30 days per month.
So we're going to do
60 jobs per month.
Let's do 50 CPUs.
No.
50 CPUs.
And 100 gigs of RAM.
And again, 1
terabyte of storage.
How much does that cost?
Let's put in Dataflow.
Nearly $200.
All right.
Now, let's try streaming.
Again, 50 CPUs.
100 gigs of RAM.
10 terabytes.
And we add that.
And that costs $4.
All right.
I think we should spend
more money on Dataflow
because $4 is just not enough.
Let's be silly.
Let's just add 10
times the capacity.
So wait, was that right?
That's 1,000.
Yeah, OK.
Same storage.
Dataflow streaming.
$36.
No, I want more.
So it's running all month long.
That's 720 hours a month.
So I've got to have at
least a CPU per hour.
So let's just do 1,000 CPUs.
And just make this
a silly number.
So Dataflow's now
up to $105 per month
adding a lot of RAM and CPU.
So that's fantastic.
So if you look at this, overall
that entire architecture
ends up costing a
little over $5,000
a month, with me probably going
a little overboard on pricing
out Dataflow.
Most of this cost is actually
driven by what BigQuery uses
and what Bigtable costs.
So the rest of all
that streaming,
the storage on Cloud Storage,
Pub/Sub, all that stuff,
actually is not a significant
cost driver to that.
But one other neat
thing that I actually
really like about this tool
is you can slide around.
OK, what would this
cost me per day?
But also, I think more usefully,
what is the quarterly cost?
What is the annual cost?
So the annual cost for
that particular pipeline,
assuming all the numbers
stay relatively close,
is about $60,000, which is
really not bad but very much
in line with the
cost that we've seen
other customers do running
similarly complex data
processing pipelines.
So we're back.
So I think walking through
that exercise is helpful.
I hope it's been helpful.
I hope that is given you a
little more understanding.
This is my manager.
Like I said, we liberally
use GIFs of each other.
And I think this one's
hilarious as well.
So that exercise,
actually that's something
that we very commonly do, is
walk through data processing
on the calculator and
help give customers
some sort of perspective
of what these actually
mean if you start
attaching numbers to them.
And once you know, then,
as the saying goes,
knowing is half the battle.
But in reality, you have to face
the other half of the battle.
And what good is
knowing what you
can do if you don't know how to
control how much cost is going
to go on your data
processing pipelines,
on your environments.
Whatever you're using, you
need to be able to control.
Otherwise, pricing it out
is kind of nice in theory,
but then you don't know what
to do and how to stop it.
And so I'd like to
talk or I'd like
to finish off the talk by
just walking through ways
you can control how much
you spend on the cloud.
And the first step
actually has nothing
to do with budgeting
or cost controls.
But actually, it's monitoring.
So if you're not
monitoring environments,
if you're not monitoring what
you're doing on your data
processing pipelines,
you literally
have no idea what's going on.
You have no idea what
developers are doing.
your systems are doing.
You have no idea how
much you've spent.
You have no idea
where you're going.
You have no idea how
to do any of this.
And so monitoring is
absolutely essential.
It's essential for a lot of
other reasons other than cost
control, but it's essential
for cost control as well.
If you're not using
monitoring yet,
I strongly recommend
Google Stackdriver.
I think it's a terrific tool.
It monitors a lot
of great things.
of things on cloud.
It actually monitors a lot
of things on AWS as well.
You can put agents in your
data center and monitor things.
So Stackdriver has a
lot of versatility.
There are some terrific
third-party tools out there
that people use for monitoring.
There have been
customers who have
written their own
terrific monitoring tools.
When I go to a customer,
really all I want to see
is that somebody is
monitoring something
with any tool that's competent.
You're monitoring
the right things.
You're looking at alerts.
That's all I really care about.
So that is really a message
I can't really kind of harp
on enough is how important it
is to have monitoring and have
monitoring for things that
matter and things that
are important.
So that's step one.
So step 2, you can actually
set budget in Google Cloud.
You can set it in the console.
You can go into any project.
You look at how
much it was spending
or it spent in the last month.
You can set a budget there.
You can set budgets on
whatever number you want.
And then you set alerts on
certain percentages of where
that spend is.
That way, you can actually
monitor throughout the month
as you spend what things
are doing, how things are
going, how much has been spent.
So it doesn't come
to you at the end
of the month like a surprise,
like a cellphone bill,
over how much you've spent.
This is actually a great way
to do cost, control and cost
monitoring.
Next, you can take advantage of
some of the features built-in
to the products themselves.
So both BigQuery
and Cloud Storage
have different storage
classes that cost different.
Cloud Storage has the
four different classes
that we looked at earlier.
There's multi-regional
and regional,
but there's also
near-line and cold line.
Near-line and cold line are
designed for archival storage
with increasingly rare access.
So near-line, we
ballpark it say,
do you need to see this
once a month or less?
Cold line is, do you need to
see this once a year or less?
And those are generally
the guidelines.
But you can take
advantage of those
because they cost
significantly less.
If you're not
touching this data,
you're not touching
this data for a while,
you need to keep it around.
Don't put it in regular
regional storage.
It's a total waste of money.
Similarly, with BigQuery,
BigQuery ages off the data
into cheaper storage if you
haven't touched it for 90 days.
And so you can take
advantage of that.
It's like, if we're only
carrying relatively hot data,
if we're only querying
relatively recent data,
then just let that age off.
Don't query that if you don't
actually need to touch it.
Dataflow, because it's
a unified programming
model for batch or stream,
it lets you actually
use that versatility long term.
So let's say as
a company, you're
processing x log data for
whatever reason in batch mode
because that makes sense
when you started doing that.
But actually, long
term you've grown.
You've switched directions.
You want to try something new.
You want to try
something different.
Dataflow gives you versatility
to change from batch mode
to stream mode by
changing two things.
There are two differences in
these code samples and only one
additional line.
That is enormous amounts of
developer time saved just
by using Dataflow so that you
have long-term versatility
to change your mind, to
change what you're doing,
change how you work.
And then, Dataproc.
One thing I think that
kind of goes unnoticed
is that because it just sits
on top of Compute Engine,
it uses all of Google Compute
Engine's storage methods.
And so sustained use
discounts, per minute billing,
preemptable VMs
are all just ready
out of the box for Dataproc.
There's nothing to enable.
There's nothing to change.
Nothing to switch.
And so you can take advantage
of those cost features
whenever you want there.
Finally, you can control
the rate of access
with different tools.
And so let's say
you're processing
in some logs again
from somewhere
that you don't control.
Somebody that-- an external
third party is feeding you data
that is not under your control.
How do you control how
quickly that comes in?
What if they send
way too much for you
to handle at a
certain cost level
that you're comfortable with?
Well, with Pub/Sub, you can set
up a topic that's a pull topic.
And when the data gets
sent into Pub/Sub,
Pub/Sub can control how
quickly to acknowledge and say,
yes, I've received your message.
Send me another one.
And so you can actually
control the rate of ingest just
with Pub/Sub with the tooling
that's already in there.
And then with
BigQuery, let's say,
for example, you
drop a huge data set
into a couple of tables.
And you want to let your
analyst loose on it.
And say, OK, guys.
Query all you want.
But you actually
don't want to spend as
much as say they want to query.
They're going to go, well, OK.
Is there a limit?
Yes, there is a limit.
And you can actually set quotas
for how much querying people
can do inside of BigQuery.
You can do it across all users.
You can do it by project.
And so that's a way of
controlling the cost
and controlling
what you're spending
on your different products.
So I hope that this kind
of gives you some idea
and gets your mind kind
of churning and thinking
about the different
ways to kind of get
the best value for what you
spend out of data processing
pipelines.
Really, it's important
to understand
what the products do first,
but then how they interact
with each other, to really
understand and really get
the best ways to budget
out what they are doing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]